c'est ce que dit aujourd'hui en
compagnie de ouais ça fait longtemps
mais longtemps qu'elle ait pas pensé de
cette vidéo et pour fêter ça on a décidé
de mettre un petit filtre sur la vidéo
je t'en prie c'est parti o o alors c'est
parti aujourd'hui on est sur mario
street street mario alors qu'est ce
qu'il est bon comme pourquoi tu fais ça
alors ça fait ou alors c'est merci moi
je prends mario malien au yes we done
moustachu et toi tu prends pitch voilà
donc on reste dans les choix mecs trois
mecs chez une fille facile c'est un peu
une classique
alors c'est parti
obama né je ne connais pas les douches
ceux ci étaient maigres bus est fixé
mais c'est juste que comme ça tous les
ans parce qu'en fait on personae
attendre la regarda une autruche
t'invite à te regarde
françois tu as fait de ce petit monde
mes jambes et mes deux plots et tu as
pris des cours de capoeira
je ne savais pas tiens tiens on peut
peut-être ndo alors ce jeu c'est du
bourrinage de claviers aura non j'allais
de faire une prise de bouclans excuse
moi je n'ai pas pu me retenir jeter et
jacques dans la phase 1 elle est à toi
non je crois quand même se protéger est
en recul à comme ça alors nous étonne
pas
ça pète [ __ ] vialattiens oui là au
deuxième round vite vite en vue du don
qui fuit d'accord donc toi tu en fait tu
es une ninja mais peut-être qu'ils font
plus mal que tu t'es fait avoir
tu t'es fait 40 schirrhein et pitch mais
cet habitat des cerises dans les cheveux
hop hop hop hop on n'a rien vu et je
repars à beaune est en panne et au
panama des eaux vives a commenté wayne
voilà à plus de monde
[Musique]
ta main de fer même coup tu crois que je
t'ai pas vu c'est de l'anti jeu sam à
petit ça s'appelle de l'anti jeu
j'attends mon fric dans les siens
bingbing pourquoi dès qu'on fait une
vidéo ensemble tu m'aimes à branler
bordel j'ai pu faire du beau avec toi
tchèque s'était pas que tu me tiens au
[ __ ] tu énorme
ouais mais tu fais peur mais dégage
voila voila merci parce que ça ça ne dit
pas à celle d'hier dans la vidéo mes
attentes et je ne sors de la souris
voilà comment on voit comment il fait
pour faire des combos dévastateurs
en tout cas je te mets mon âge mais
aussi
o la contre attaque elle a fait mal elle
a fait mal dans les coins du bugue what
went ufg halo vague et ce qui t'arrive
mégawatts mais alors oui mais mais
qu'est ce qui t'arrive attend juste et
qu'elle a un poids mais qu'est ce que tu
as à temps je sais j'étais décoince
tient aux [ __ ] touche empilés tous
morts tu es petit tu tu as vu comment il
marche je te dis c'est un gangster en
réalité voilà il vend des champi à la
résille marche lorsque final c'est que
en fait quand je vois juste je connais
aucune touche et tué sa femme sa fille
géniale je sais pas c'est quoi ton
attachement au club
tu veux un produit tu veux des lunettes
désolé excuse-moi par d'oman tu sais que
la partie commence un jeu mais tu fais
mais arrête avec tes pompes the biggest
l'arachide le pédicure y ait trop de lag
pendant le mois saint
veinard vraiment n'importe quoi comment
t'es tu ne sais pas je comprends pas
comment on fait pour arrêter les coûts
m'arrêter là tu vois un sol en devient
l'insolente non je vais tout mais je
fais tout ce que je peux tu me remplit
de me déconcentrer tu veux mouvement de
lèvres et où la saboter vraiment
apprécié est-ce que j'ai affiché ton
petit secret devant tout le monde
mais [ __ ] mais tu vas bomba
j'abandonne est-ce qu'on fait incarnent
un dernier de chez dernier combat
d'accord mais tu es quelqu'un qui a un
bon bah écoutez merci la coupole cette
vidéo un attendant je vous ordonne de
vous
mais à bientôt